i'm a big believer that regression of
the mean is a force of nature i gotta
argue with someone say oh the markets
can just keep going up i said no they
can't 20 percent of the s p can't pay
their interest payments with their cash
flow these are the 500 biggest companies
in the united states the overarching
theory that covers all these concerns of
ours is that someone's trying to destroy
us do you believe that well let me ask
you this are we trying to destroy putin
i think the s p is going to unwind sub
2000. there's people right now who are
going to hear you say that and they're
going to go shut their computer and walk
go for a walk outside what do you
disagree with
all right guys i have dave here i don't
know we've recorded two or three times
this one's gonna be the best one because
we live in the most chaotic times
uh let's maybe start with the easy stuff
uh the federal reserve they for i don't
know months told us inflation is
transitory news flash doesn't seem so
transitory they now are saying that
they're going to create tighter
financial conditions and that will bring
down inflation doesn't seem to
necessarily be working what's your
general read on the federal reserve as
the market maker and ultimately the
judge the jury and the executioner of
financial assets right now
i don't think they have control of of
the inflation at all you know um roach
warned about it in an article about two
years ago that they were
making the same mistake as arthur burns
um
uh smart guys i know like einhorn and
stuff all say it's gotten into the dna
uh the question i like to ask
rhetorically is if you're a contractor
and you were going to build a house two
years from now what what sort of uh
markup would you put on on materials and
labor
to bid that house and the number would
not be three percent
so that's the inflation expectation
problem and i think i think it's i think
it's profound um
the idiots who say because inflation
held firm and eight and a half percent
which we can ignore the you know it's
not eight and a half percent story
um it's much higher but um
uh jimmy iorio yesterday said his
restaurants doing 23 24
um in any event um
um
the headline was that it it didn't go up
anymore
and and then kamala uh the rocket
surgeon said therefore there was no
inflation
so it's sitting at eight and a half
percent by official number she said
therefore there's no inflation i go uh
kamal you should have taken calculus
that's a second derivative thing you're
talking about there
so
when you see this so uh i think using
the construction example is a perfect
way to look at uh markets to look at uh
how the real economy works and uh i
don't know what the answer is in terms
of a contractor that is looking to bid a
house that will be built you know forget
two years just one year from now right
and i agree it's not three percent uh
and i actually think they don't know and
so some of that is just them causing
slowdowns them trying to wait uh when we
saw the explosion in lumber prices there
was a ton of people saying like we have
no clue where this price will be 30 days
from now let alone you know six months
or 12 months from now and so i guess
less about the specifics of the numbers
but just when you have so much
volatility in various parts of the
economy and so much uncertainty what are
the second and third order effects of
that should we expect there to be
breaking of additional things across the
economy just because people are scared
or people are uncertain of the future or
has markets always operated this way and
maybe it's just being magnified because
we're seeing big inflation numbers
well
to the extent that you we've all seen
over and over and over numbers quoted
saying that the average person doesn't
have four hundred dollars to to to
replace a microwave if uh if it breaks
and now the cheap ones cost 400 so
that's a good number um
to the extent that
they say that
the median family doesn't have that then
if all of a sudden you tack on let's say
conservatively eight and a half nine ten
percent
increase costs annualized uh where is
that money gonna come from
and and so i think you can hear you know
uh glass shattering you know teeth
flying around the room now because i
think the average family can't pay the
bills yeah and as we see this obviously
uh core inflation tends to be a metric
that uh economists and politicians love
to point to i see you shaking your head
uh core inflation having uh all the
things that you actually consume not
included uh which is you know some big
brain uh mathematical uh analysis
what what should we actually be paying
attention to is the cpi number the thing
to watch is it uh something like real
wage growth like how do you actually
analyze uh via the data that we are
provided what's going on
well ironically um
i mean remember when inflation was low
and everyone was ranting about how it
would be great if they had inflation i
thought it would somehow
deal with their
their mortgages and stuff and i'm going
you guys have no understanding of
inflation
no one who's lived through a serious
inflation which i'm old enough to
remember in high school
uh and in college no one who's lived
through it knows that it's good news
anyone who's lived through it knows it's
good it's bad news um these guys who say
somehow it's going to erode their debt
or something or dreaming because their
their their wages are not going to keep
up and when the wages catch up then you
have all these secondary effects like uh
well first and foremost the markets are
going to cut their profit margins in
half easily
because of the labor costs
and uh
and and so they're going to have to
either jack up prices which is going to
make it even worse or they're not going
to be able to jack up prices which means
that the market's just doubled valuation
so
there's things like that um
there's just so many what do you do if
you've signed a contract for five years
for i have a dog in my lap so it's going
to be a little jiggly here what do you
do if you've signed a contract for five
years also than your cost of goods and
services or the projections are just
way the hell wrong this gets back to the
house
but but there are long-term contracts
you know there's people who have you
know five-year wage contracts because
they signed them
their union reps signed them back in
2019. i don't know it's just it's just
nothing good comes of inflation yeah and
people who think it does they're just
have just not seen inflation before and
when we look at something like the labor
market uh obviously the federal reserve
and many other organizations continue to
point to a strong labor market and
they're specifically looking at the
unemployment rate sitting you know 3.5
3.6
uh open rolls in america 10 11 million
depending on the week uh
is it something where the labor market
will be a lagging indicator of a
recession or trouble and we should
expect those numbers to degrade in the
coming months or can we actually get
this like stagflationary period and the
labor market stay strong but people are
being hurt on the real wage front
well you put in a premise there um
i i don't think it's a strong labor
market i think it's a broken labor
market
so you look at labor force participation
it's pathetic it's it's bad
and so
the fact is somehow
labor and management are not needing eye
to eye to come up with
with with a
working arrangement um
means that price discovery in the labor
market is broken i i just
i i would never call this a strong labor
market
it i i'd call it tight
but it's tight because it's not working
right
the food market is tight when there's no
bread on the shelves right same thing
yeah explain a little bit more what you
mean by uh it's tight but it's not
working
well again back to labor force
participation we've got a ton of people
are not working and i can't even tell
you why it's it's a surreal thing it's
like if you walked out in the woods and
there was no no birds and no squirrels
and you go there's something wrong here
right there's something creepy quiet
and uh
and whenever i ask
um and every establishment i go into
everyone they look understaffed to me
and they act under staff right so you're
getting lousy service you're a walmart
you can't find anyone to ask a question
to right that sort of thing you go to a
restaurant they're short of labor
they've got signs in the door help
wanted
and i asked them where are your workers
where did they go if they're not working
here and they always say oh somewhere
else but i haven't found this mystical
mystical employer
they just and i don't know how they're
putting food on the table so i'm just
completely and utterly baffled if
someone knows send me an email dbc6
cornell.edu you know anything about
anything that i don't know about send me
an email my email box is a shitstorm but
you know
can't get much worse
so when you look at the labor market uh
every restaurant that i go to uh i asked
two questions you know how much have
prices increased uh here it's never
eight point five percent it always tends
to be teens or higher uh and then also i
see the help wanted signs uh on top of
it and i always ask well how much have
you tried to raise the pay in order to
elicit uh applications and so there's a
restaurant here uh in miami that uh i
recently was talking to and he's like i
need dishwashers he said i used to be
able to pay you know 10 then it was 12
then it was 14. he's like now we're
offering 18. can't get anyone and he has
no clue he's just as perplexed as you
are in terms of where where did everyone
go why is it that we've increased uh
over the last you know three years or so
from 10 to 18 and we still can't get
anyone to fill the role
and so i thought that was really weird
18
for a dishwasher uh feels like a high
price given maybe where we're all
anchored but then i went and i started
to look at other
average wages and amazon for example the
average amazon worker gets paid over 17
an hour they're paying some people you
know 20 22 24
and so it feels like wages although they
are going up in aggregate dollar amount
they're not keeping up with inflation
but it's a very different story than
maybe what the mainstream talking points
are of like you know amazon screws over
their workers like politicians are
trying to implement 15 an hour amazon's
paying 17.
it just feels to your point like i'm
confused and i don't know why i'm
confused but i don't understand what's
happening
well the one theory i heard from an uber
smart uber famous guy and i never know
what i should name a name or not but um
you'd know him if i said his name
he had him over for dinner and he
pointed out two important things one is
he said that
unrelated but still worth putting in
your quiver
that 18 trillion dollars with the us
debt is going to roll over in the next
two years 18 trillion 18
trillion um
and then he said that uh he thought that
maybe it was during the lockdown the uh
the
illegal aliens had to go home because
there was nothing here
and then they haven't made it back
that's it it strikes me as a funny
trickle-up economics right these guys
were kind of off radar but if if also
there's a couple million people missing
then this then you're playing uh
you know some screwy game at connect
four or something where it's it's it's
the patterns are changing i don't know
yeah one of the uh the the themes i
don't know maybe through the end of last
year was a great resignation all these
people were quitting their jobs even in
the beginning of this year uh and what i
don't know how to measure but it feels
like a lot of these folks when they
created jobs for themselves but they're
not actually creating what we would
traditionally think of as a business and
they're also not going and filling other
open roles so an easy example would be
uh if somebody leaves their job and they
start uh a sub stack newsletter
which seems really good there's a real
wealth creator huh right well if you
think about it right now all of a sudden
it's like hey i have all this freedom
and we you know we'll get into kind of
the the pros and cons of the freedom of
movement and the freedom not to go into
the office versus like how much money
you make and and kind of your ability to
invest capital and and reach financial
security but it just feels like there's
a lot of things like that but it doesn't
feel like there's millions of people who
did that so it's still even if you
account for these you know kind of
non-traditional jobs or these
non-traditional uh essentially company
create creations
there's still a ton of people missing
from the labor force that no one seems
to be able to find
well
the worst i heard is i had a couple of
guys deliver a
washing machine
um
and i asked them that question and one
of them said he actually is
he's a truck driver he just muscles the
watch which is a big burly guy
he he is up from georgia and they put
him in a hotel
at night he drives a truck around new
england
and uh and and i i asked him where is
everyone and he said they're trading
bitcoin
i go well that's really gotten
profitable over the last few months um
so in any case i i don't have an answer
it really is a mystery to me and it's
but it
but it tells me something's broken right
there's something so eerie and creepy in
in the world and
and uh it's just one more log on the
bonfire of why the hell is the world
what it is and i i've just never felt
it feels like i'm in some sci-fi movie
or something yeah when when we switch
from labor force maybe we look at uh
things like shelter the cpi uh
calculation 33 percent of it is uh
shelter they still are estimating that
it is uh non-existent five percent
increase or something year over year uh
but real estate prices are up you know
near 20
rents are up near 20
uh so the first question you know that i
always ask is like how do they calculate
shelter if rent and real estate are both
up 20 but they say it's up five uh but
is this just a continuation like as
things get confusing as things break
across the market we'll continue to see
bad data and we'll also continue to see
uh parts of the market that used to be
uh very important and very well
understood we should expect to just have
less and less understanding moving
forward
well this gets to the question of the
the the uh
the uh
housing and and rental markets being
either uh
broken or
are having changed profoundly in the
last decade
and so we go through that great building
boom from from iran it started around
1998 um actually the first writings of a
subprime crisis were in 98 i wrote about
in 2002
i thought the banking system would
collapse soon it took five more years um
but then what happened is we get the
collapse and then the question is okay
so you have this massive inventory of
houses where did they all go
and and who bought them and why why what
how did that inventory get absorbed
and and this gets to a theory of of uh
some off off broadway thinkers who say
that that it was actually sort of a
hostile take over the housing market by
permanent capital so
um so they say the housing bubble's
bigger now but you don't see the froth
in the housing bubble yeah i mean the
fact is you know they're all cash deals
and there's people bidding like crazy
but but you don't have the condo
flippers you don't have the crazy you
don't have the people you don't have the
euphoria so it doesn't feel the same
what i think happened and the number
that i've i'm about to quote a number
that
that was from a credible source but it's
an incredible number
and that is that um
i think permanent capital bought up all
those houses so big huge tranches of
money coming out of blackrock and places
like that
um and i think they scooped it all up
now a single
occupant single single-family dwellings
are a terrible terrible business
and the only way you make that a good
business you know you're supposed to
make something like 1 7. of the the cost
of the house per year for it to be
profitable right that's a historical
number and no it's getting that so so
the question is how's it working well it
turns out you get there by getting cheap
capital and and and heavy leverage
and what i heard was is that blackrock
who who clearly was scooping up bass
fast squads and single-family housing
and buying up companies who are scooping
it up and stuff like that so you had
these these aggregators it's sort of
like in uh like in russia where you had
aggregators with the russian chits after
the berlin wall fell and then people
would buy the chits off the aggregators
and so blackrock i heard was
was getting uh
money
at point one five percent
so if you can if you can make point one
five percent on a rental net
um above 0.5 percent so if you can make
point three percent
then you've got a profitable business
now that's just absurdity right that's
just that's just a broken market again
and so
at some point i'm a big believer that
regression of the mean is a force of
nature i i got to argue with someone say
oh the markets can just keep going up i
said no no they can't they they they
won't they that you know the credit
cycle will end everything will end
everything comes to an end
and and it starts all over again and
someone shakes the dam at saskatchewan
we all end up paying for it um
and and
we we will have a bust and and i think
what's going to happen is
again i've mentioned several podcasts so
i feel like i'm recycling here but um
different
the overlap of podcasts is so small
um
i i i i have two
black swans in my skull and obviously
they're not my black swans because
they're in my skull so they can't be a
blacksmith but i think for the average
investor there'll be a black swan and
one is that the fed grew a spine
and and it's not going to stop
now the equity investors really ought to
be troubled
in general because it seems clear to me
that the fed is going to keep hiking
until
that something breaks
now people forget what something breaks
me their defaults their their their
their collapses their they're world cups
they're enrons they're they're they're
bad things
and and those were during a generic
collapse then you get to the big
collapse like 1809. i think this one
will be bigger i i think the next one
will be bigger than 0-809 and part of it
is because the inflation's going to box
them in so so the fed's going to keep
hiking until it breaks and breaking
doesn't mean a 20 drop of the dow
breaking means broken bones right icu's
this is this is what they'll do and so
as long as the markets keep going up as
long as the collapses are not showing up
yet
um
then then i don't see a mechanism by
which the fed will stop
and
and
again i finally got an answer to a
question i didn't have for a long long
time is you know guys like james grant
say twenty percent of yes and fear
zombies twenty percent of the s p can't
pay their their their interest payments
with their cash flow these are the 500
biggest companies in the united states
and they can't pay their interest
payments for their cash flow now to
calibrate you you go back to the late
90s i think it was the late 90s but
somewhere in the 90s
the zombie count
was was two percent and the interest
rates were nine percent so this shows
you how out of whack we are so
when those guys break
and and 100 of the s p 500
can't pay their interest payments
and the fed is boxed in by horrible
inflation what's going to happen i i
just don't know but i think
i think there'll be a lot of people
being brought in on their shields
carried off the battlefield so when you
look at this you mentioned that the fed
has grown a spine obviously uh they've
talked i'm not sure they have that
that's black that's black swan number
one okay i don't know if they have but
now black's one number two is that they
they pivot as they like to say
and and it doesn't work
and all of a sudden the metrics just
keep doing what they're doing and and
things go bad and you find out that the
fed
is finally out of ammo and the way i
like to describe this you know the
40-year credit cycle
is a
it is a that's that's a typical length
of a credit cycle supposedly i i you
know i'd have to ask lacey hunt to fill
in those details but um but but credit
cycles are very long and sluggish things
and if it's over
then the game's over right the whole
equity game is over um we're going to go
through a tough period and uh
and so uh
again 18 trillion rolling over who's
gonna buy all that debt which i just
don't i i have trouble picking this is
stage four cancer
and and and you say well what do you do
and the answer is you put your ferris
note
yeah
when you look at it if the fed let's go
through both these scenarios if the fed
did grow a spine and they continue to
hike raids how high do you think the
rates can get before things would break
right there's a lot of folks who say hey
they can't get to five or six percent
interest rates because you know the us
will default and the system will break
and and kind of all these problems how
do you just think through maybe
how high could it actually go
well it could be they're already there
and it's just time now right it could be
that the that remember in
um
in 0809
i i literally told my class in march of
2007 that i thought the banking system
was about to collapse and this was not
me analyzing spreadsheets it's just
reading smart guys
and uh
and and and
but most people couldn't see the cracks
the housing market cracked you know s
and no six
and so the housing market had already
peaked and so that game was over and so
that was a systemic problem
and uh
but it took it takes markets and takes
things
if you put a 20-pound block of ice out
on the street in 95 degree weather it
wouldn't just turn to water it takes
time there's kinetics to the process
so it could already be there um but the
fed will keep biking because the fed
will keep hiking into
until the breaking occurs
and that's why they overshoot because
there's a lag right it's like driving up
driving a car with loose steering right
you you go to turn and it doesn't
respond right away so you turn harder
next you know your fishtail yeah
it uh it reminds me a lot of last year
they were still conducting qe and still
suppressing interest rates and we had
seven percent inflation like talk about
overshooting uh just absolute in
hindsight insanity and it feels like uh
they are likely to repeat that now on
the other end of the spectrum uh because
they're gonna wait till it breaks and
then it takes time for them to pivot it
takes time for the market to internalize
that pivot and kind of work its way
through
so is this just now a game where the fed
will continue to overshoot in each
direction as we kind of go through boom
and bust cycles and
there's just nothing they can do about
it or do we need somebody to step in
there and say hey
let's stop the madness and prevent
ourselves from overshooting uh and try
to look forward rather than look
backwards in data
i don't know
um
the thing we should
and this is not
in isolation either right so before
we're done we will talk about all the
[ __ ] up things
that might completely remove the control
from the fed right
wars and famines and you know just
there's so many waves of fed you can't
the fed can't print wheat the fed can't
print natural gas the fed can't print
oil
um
so so um
and so
i i i
i i'm in a loss to see how this plays
out this is again the stage 4 cancer
model
i i i feel like it's it's game over but
i'm sitting going i'm having trouble
picturing this whole death thing you
know it's kind of not working yet for me
right what do you mean it's game over is
it game over in terms of like a us
default it's uh just so much stuff
breaks in the system that it you know
goes back to the the analogy of like
shaking the etch a sketch and we start
over what does that mean i
when i say game over i mean i think
we're going to get a generational
wake-up call so the 40-year credit cycle
so yeah
there's a guy named murray stalin
horizon kinetic so i've i've been
following for years
but but i listen i got invited to listen
to one of their internal conference
calls due to a friend at rbc and uh
murray's a genius and and he said in uh
early 1980s two miraculous things
happened one is
russia was collapsing
they weren't done yet but they were
starting to and they desperately needed
capital and all they had were resources
so they just flooded the world with
resources
china was coming out of its medieval
period
and and they desperately needed capital
all that was labor so this whole labor
dirt cheap and so we've had 40 years of
unlimited resources unlimited labor
and and he says that's not to be
repeated
i would add on top of that a 40-year
credit cycle superimpose right on top of
it although it's possible the 40-year
credit cycle somehow because of that
right
maybe maybe maybe volcker didn't
slight inflation at all
maybe maybe those two miraculous things
are what stopped inflation
um
and and there's just things like that
that that that just keep occurring we
started with um
we started with interest rates at 16
they went below two 30-year rates
how and and
you know if you if you use the fed model
which i agree with at one level i think
the idea that somehow rates correlate
with equity
prices where i disagree violently with
the fed model is that you use interest
rates to justify
the equity prices because in that case
you're not explaining it you're
justifying it and and you can say oh you
can say well you know equity prices are
fair value because interest rates are so
low and i go so you're gonna you're
gonna justify interest rates uh equity
prices by comparing it to the biggest
bubble in history the biggest the most
gargantuan bubble in history
have a ball with that but you know just
because someone bought a toyota for 150
000 doesn't mean i'm going to buy a
honda for 170.
right it just doesn't work that way
you're still screwed either way
if we go to the other black swan of the
fed potentially pivoting uh midterm
elections i think is one reason why
people are saying oh they'll never go
into the midterm elections with uh high
inflation or a recession you know
shocker maybe we'll get both uh as we go
don't follow that at all i don't buy
that at all explained
i think the midterm elections are
already written down
i think i think you know the democrats
are desperately trying to achieve
something but it's probably not the
midterm elections
so i think what you do is you let i
think i think this is where you
euthanize the patient you let the
republicans
grab control of congress and the senate
and you just let it go it's it's too
late right you're in a barrel you're
going down the niagara river you know
help do something sorry it's too late
you're done
yeah so the midterms are right off
unless
they're not at which point um
did you see that that election and flo
that recall vote in california where
where they were recalling one of they
say one of soros's appointments i just
feel creepy saying that
and and uh
they discounted they threw out 30 of the
votes they threw the the paul watchers
out they did the same thing over again
so so if if if the midterm elections
somehow if there's a you know
miracle on ice moment
and the democrats managed to hold power
i will never believe another election
yeah
i already not sure i will ever believe
in other elections i think they've been
playing capture the flag for years
actually but but the the anti-trump one
of 2020
i'm a big believer they rigged it i i i
i would comfortably bet yeah to me it's
a lot it'd be a lot safer bet than an s
p index fund to me
explain that more in terms of like why
are you so confident
well first of all i think the data's
there some more stuff came out with the
you know 2000 mules but i i watched it i
read about it there's just so many
things that just didn't make sense to me
and then on top of that the the the drop
dead argument
is that they've done everything
imaginable
to take trump out of the kneecaps right
everything imaginable they've corrupted
the fbi they've done everything
but they forgot to rig the election i
don't think so
i find that not even imaginable
they rigged them yeah i don't doubt it
and and people say well there was 61
court case they didn't win any of them
they never made it to evidentiary
standards none of them that's the rig
the rig is that not a single case went
to court
they ended up in the courtroom but
didn't go to trial they never got
adjudicated so one of the things that
i've asked folks uh on both sides of
this right some people believe hey i
can't trust it some people say you know
that those are the results is i always
ask it's about that spouse yeah yeah
well and what i say to them is i say
listen um do you think that one hundred
percent of people who have voted in
every single election there's been no
errors
and people say no but it's question no
it's worse than that though
i mean that that's that there's going to
be scrubs matter what dead guys have
been voting since they started voting
right um
but but i think it was wholesale i think
it was i think it was so inadvance
rigged
where um
where they they made sure that they
didn't go to bed that night
wondering who would win
that they made sure that that that they
would have the votes by morning
and uh
and and and the mail and ballots and the
whole thing was set up perfectly for the
rig so this is the big difference in my
opinion right is to your point about
like dead people been voting in
elections forever right it's usually
been nice yeah it's usually been such a
small percentage that it doesn't sway
the outcome and uh i think most people
they don't like to think about it that
way it's true in every country
you're trying to get millions and
millions of people to all cast some you
know votes on something and so that
happens whatever
what you're talking about though seems
to be something that is much more uh
malicious nefarious uh playing deep
state total deep state okay so here
here's let me let me dial it back though
wikileaks had emails about election
rigging there were emails that suggested
i can't remember which the two
candidates won pennsylvania because of
rigging it came out of a wikileak and
stuff like that
but years ago when i think when bush jr
was running um
youtube was filled with with computer
scientists showing how you could rig a
machine in a heartbeat right so again
but that's kind of the the capture the
flag baloney stuff that's just kind of
the gaming that they do
and since both candidates were
pre-vetted that didn't really matter
they didn't care who won and it was
probably relatively balanced battle um
but but
but i think it was during the bush
election the ceo of diebold which
controlled the voting machines at the
time
um was a bush fundraiser a big one and
and there's just no mechanism that that
that's legit right that just shouldn't
exist if you're controlling the voting
machines you should shut your mouth
and stay out of it and uh
and then of course the voting machines
rolled over to um to dominion now here's
the the horror story of dominion
dominion's a canadian company
and you go okay so a for a foreign
sovereign state controls our voting
machines that makes me nervous although
i'm not sure i trust him any less than
than we
controlling our voting machines but it
turns out dominion um
the dominion um
uh ceo had done big favors for for for
the bite he was involved in the biden
transition
and and then you say okay that's a
problem but then you find out dominion's
actually a subsidiary of a subsidiary of
ubs
and you go okay that's a problem
therefore it's not only owned by a
sovereign state but it's not even canada
and then you find out that that
subsidiary is largely owned by
a company in beijing
so our voting machines are owned by
beijing and that then the plot thickens
when you remember that
the voting machines the voting system
was
was was connected to the internet that
night
and a lot of people don't know what that
means what means that from across the
world they could they could change all
the votes
is this something that moving forward
will always
now be part of the conversation like the
united states uh historically was the
legitimacy of elections the legitimacy
of various organizations it was taboo it
wasn't even a conversation uh without
somebody saying you know go put your
tinfoil hat on and sit in the corner
now
i see it on every mainstream side i see
the democratic you know mainstream
conversation i see the republican
mainstream conversation
it feels like the conversation across
the board is very very different in 2022
than it was in 2019 uh before a lot of
this stuff happened
well so you know
i'm
i i certainly lean right
but that's not to say that i like
republicans um
and and so i voted for bush jr who i
didn't like uh the first time and not
the second time because he he [ __ ] up
completely right he he got us into a war
he killed
upwards of a million people and it was
all baloney and so that to me
for years have been put in the war crime
category the weapons mass destruction
was the complete ruse you know you can't
let a guy get away with that i mean he
should be taken to the hague for that
one um
but um
i
i i think people are reaching a point
where they feel like they don't have
anyone on their side
and i think that's where the populism is
popping populism is both left and right
revolutions which i think we're in i
think we're in a nasty one actually but
it's it's it's
it's under the surface but it's real
they can come from the left or the right
and i think this one is coming from the
left so this is you know the whole
critical race theory the whole the whole
getting rid of religion the whole um
they're just almost every topic the
january six hearings the the the rigging
the election so so to me the left seem
like the guilty party
largely now
and the right look like they're being
responsive they're they're just getting
irritated
um
i think january 6th
the moment was optically ugly i think
january 6 the response to that moment is
is horrific
explain that so uh
well there's several there's that on you
one is the role of the fbi on january 6
is is
undeniable we just we don't have good
numbers but you know someone explained
larry epps right but there were many
many more there's an estimated 80
co-conspirators who didn't get indicted
who certainly looked like feds
when
when the smashing of the windows and the
smashing of the doors and the damage and
the rallying is done by feds
what kind of a country have we become
and so then
it's a great example right q and shaman
boy right he's nuts right they say he's
unstable i know what what gave you that
idea right
he's wearing a we're not a viking helmet
um
he
broke nothing he walked through an open
door they've been open from the inside
he he he hurt nobody
and he got um
i think it was four or seven years in
prison
how do you get that i don't understand
i i can't i'm not even sure what crime
he committed i'm sure there's some
trespassing crime
but that's that's
the nest's the democrats
so you guys can rot in hell you
democratic operatives who did that to
that guy and who put you know what 700
people in prison in solitary without
trial for the longest time and and
threatened you know 20 30-year jail
sentences and stuff like that
i hope you eat [ __ ] and die i i i would
i i it's you go any further than that i
i think it's lock and load time by the
red states
is this something where um
[Music]
both sides of the aisle are just
ratcheting up the response to each other
and what i mean by that is you you see
um
uh you know i i don't know you see the
language used you see the
constant like one-upping of each other
and maybe some of this is just like
social media pulls to the extremes uh
but then also you're starting to see
action as well and you can see something
like i don't know ron desantis going
after disney and then you see something
like gavin newsom uh doing things in
california that is causing people to
leave the state and you just kind of see
these different uh things and i think to
the people who
like to believe that they're rational or
somewhat centrist they say to themselves
like the world is going crazy and like
i'm confused as to how we got here this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod three you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to hsleep.com
today to go ahead and get 150 off your
order
eightsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company
8sleep.com go get yourself an
eight-sleep pod and get a better night
of sleep
i i see i that's why i said the
republicans are being responsive
um i see
ice
um
i see um the democrats
as the ones who are taking it to the
next level every time right now that's
why i clarify between you know left and
right based revolutions but uh to me the
republicans look like they're playing
defense i i don't i don't
so so the whole thing at some level
started from the republicans many years
ago i think gingrich
turned politics ugly i think i think he
decided it was time to take off the
gloves and start bashing people so i
think the republicans get credit for for
starting the brawl i think uh as much as
clinton's the sleazeball sociopath
i should clarify bill clinton's
leaseball sociopath um not that they're
not both but it was an ambiguous
sentence um
that's not good we have a president
who's accused of being a rapist
i did we have a president who's accused
of having a body count right this is
this is a problem
but but but even with that said you know
the republicans going after him on a
perjury charge and stuff like that these
are procedural things and i i
so in many ways republicans started it
um but now the democrats have picked up
their a game the censorship is coming
out of the republic of the left right
the censorship was all left-wing
i i don't see republicans censoring the
left
at all says again send me an email if if
if if trying to stop teaching
gender theory to five-year-olds is
censorship then i guess you could
stretch the definition but um
but if i was a parent with a
five-year-old the kid came home and told
me what they're teaching their that kid
in school i i
did you see the guy who got hauled out
of a town a school board meeting because
his daughter had been raped in a
bathroom by a transgender
no i did not
yeah so he's the school board meeting
his daughter had been raped by a
transgender and the school board tried
to hide it
now they've obviously eventually got the
guy
and it's a guy
right if you're rape and girls
you're a dude right yeah you can pretend
all you want about the others but the
rape is
there's something wrong there and then
he goes to the school board he's mad as
a hornet
and and they haul him out of it the cops
haul them out and i'm going i i'm amazed
that he took that avenue
to get to the school board i i'm still
i'm i'm actually baffled we're not
seeing frontier justice vigilante
justice i
my daughter gets raped
someone's gonna die yeah
there is um
i forget the name of the the person now
maybe we can uh we can pull it up uh in
a second or look it up uh but i think
there's a ufc fighter
who someone in his family uh was
sexually uh assaulted uh and maybe even
raped i i can't remember exact details
uh but he went after him and uh right
ended up getting arrested um
and if you're in the jury if you're in
the jury you're gonna convict that guy
i i tend to think that uh uh if you're
the prosecutor you don't want to go to a
jury
well but if the prosecutor is a
left-winger
you don't know
this is the problem
and uh
if you're or should i say dishonorable
how's that to be more fair then there's
the guy lone survivor right remember
that the navy ceo who the only survivor
of a
a raid in afghanistan or something
and
and some guy shot his dog
so he hopped in his truck and he's
chased him down and he called the cops
he said you got to help me here because
if i catch him i'm killing him
and the cops intervened and got him and
the guy got something like three years
in jail which is exactly what the hell
should happen
yeah right that that's i know that any
nut but but these guys didn't know what
they were doing they were just punk ass
kids but but but but that is
there are there are crimes to me that
are
that on paper
are not as bad as they are in reality
so if you shoot your spouse
who knows what the story is
but there are things that happen where
you go oh that that really they don't
even have to be capital offenses i o but
that's
that's deeply bad
so yeah well one of the um the pieces uh
that seems to be missing from the
mainstream uh conversation around you
know guns uh crime all this uh remember
in the indiana mall
there was a i think he's like a 22 year
old kid he i think the way the story was
told was he was sitting in the food
court with his girlfriend
and a guy walked out of the bathroom
started shooting people and it was in
like he plugged him 18 seconds
right in 18 seconds he pulled out a gun
and he took him down and
he was a nationally ranked marksman
based on base and his performance from
40 yards he hit him seven out of eight
shots and with a handgun and and you
look at that and again like i'm always
careful in that i don't think anyone uh
wants to live in a society where uh we
basically return back to like the okay
corral we just you know hey let's meet
at high noon and everyone pull out guns
and start firing at each other uh but it
does
bring a point of um
there's the gun control debate
there's also uh the armed citizens being
able to protect themselves and then i
think you start thinking of these like
sanctuary cities or these kind of uh
decriminalization from the prosecutors
versus uh actually having the laws
changed
and it gets in this weird world where
you start to say like this is a very
complex issue
but i think if we focus on
the majority of citizens want to live in
a safe society where they can go about
their business and they are not worried
about getting robbed
getting their things stolen
or having to deal with violence on a
day-to-day basis
a lot of the complexity starts to look a
little bit more clear as long as we
agree like that is the goal
but when you hear some of these people
talk
i don't know if that is the goal like
there seems to be other goals that are
competing with just like let's create a
safe society for the average citizen
well so the so so the overarching theory
um
that covers all these concerns of ours
is that someone's trying to destroy us
do you believe that
uh well certainly well let me ask you
this are we trying to destroy putin
depends who you
ask right if you ask me the answer is
yes
and uh
and so there's no reason to believe that
there's not quid pro quo's around the
world um there's no reason to believe
that china isn't necessarily trying to
rot their system you know the united
states
has become a pretty serious folly now i
know that there was an upside to it i'm
reading a book right now by peter zehan
i think that's how i pronounced his name
and he's a he's an ex stratfor guy
um which is the the intelligence analog
of blackwater um
and and
and and he talks about this sort of
thing
and and it's
i lost my train of thought but but in
any event um
yeah i think i think there are groups
that are trying to undermine the united
states so we quit
oh the point being is is that the
arrangement we had post wars the united
states would keep the peace and that
would promote global trade
right
the united states
the times is not keeping the peace
i i mean i i get it when i got into it
over ukraine you we'd go to ukraine
ukraine
the ukraine story is a total mess i i
don't think i don't think any part of
that story is true i i think the entire
the mainstream media's presentation of
ukraine story is just i think it's just
fictional what do you think
what parts of what they're telling us do
you think are inaccurate or erroneous
the pressure their lips were moving
the
as soon as ukraine showed up and right
away you picked up the propaganda right
it was like it was like biscuits
flattered with you know sausage gravy
and um
and so what what i did is uh i'd always
been somewhat intrigued by putin
um and i went back and i binge watched
everything putin
i uh i uh i went back and read articles
about ukraine that that were pre 2022
which which which one could argue are
going to be more accurate because
they're not trying to justify a war in
ukraine
and what you discover
is the the the constant conflict between
nato and russia
and
here's what i'll tell you from binging
putin
putin uh
putin's a tough guy
there's no chance that a guy who's not a
tough guy can run russia so if you
somehow think you know uh you know
justin trudeau is going to run russia
you're dreaming um
he
when he answers questions
he is unbelievably direct
and and you listen to him you go
that sounds truthful
it just
there was just no sugar coating
and and so he he gets asked about you
know dealing with oligarchs
and he doesn't say i whack them because
right so he doesn't fess up to
everything or i locked him up because
what his response to dealing with the
oligarchs is they robbed russia blind
and they did
they absolutely robbed russia blind but
but so when you listen to putin you go
god damn it this guy is to the point
every he doesn't duck questions
his his answers don't seem evasive well
every once while he you sense one that
he doesn't want to put an answer to but
for the most part they're good
then you start reading about about nato
and when the the wall collapsed you know
nato made all sorts of promises to
russia that they wouldn't you know try
to scoop up all these
all these states
um
surrounding russia
and they they had told russia that why
because well nato's sole purpose
is to oppose russia
so so if you if you want to say well
putin you know it's [ __ ] about the
existential risk i go
when you've got this entire organization
of countries
whose sole purpose is to oppose your
country that in itself
is existential risk yeah they don't have
to be acting
in a risky way but it is existential
risk now
every time russia gets attacked
it's been attacked by
armies moving through ukraine ukraine is
to russia as mexico is to us
if we if russia was putting
troops on the border of mexico how many
seconds would it take for us to bomb the
live and piss out of them the answer is
uh i i don't think you'd even see the
flash i i think it would just be over
and um
and so
but where the real problem came is that
putin repeatedly repeatedly
said to nato you can't have ukraine
and and you can say well he doesn't have
the right to say that they go well we
said you can't have cuba
and we've said all sorts of things you
can't do
when i really get desperate arguing with
the the ukrainian weeper
and i feel terrible for the ukrainians
they're going to get slaughtered there's
no question the victims here are the
ukrainians this is an awful situation
but i don't get lost in that part of the
story
the story is that it's nato versus
russia
and and and when i really get frustrated
i say okay in the last 20 years which
country has bombed up more other
countries and killed more people rushed
to the united states
and and they all oh uh you know they
make up some argument about you know why
we did what we did and i said okay we
obama bombed seven muslim countries
which of those countries attacked us
he bombed seven of them which of those
detectives the answers none
none
so why is that not a war crime
when we elect a liberal democrat are we
supposed to stay out of wars
one of the basal things you might hope
to get out of a liberal democrat is not
being wars well we apparently didn't do
that very well so we've killed millions
so statistically speaking the united
states is a bad guy statistically
speaking you can't make a case against
it
so then
putin approaches nato repeatedly and
says look it's existential risk for us
so sovereign states have issues that
aren't necessarily backed by legal
uh rural legal tribunals but they have
issues they got to deal with it so when
we're talking to russia and russia is
talking united states
which is nato
there's no difference it's just the
united states
um
it's one thing for the two to say to be
negotiating saying we can't give that up
or you can't have this or that or that
you're negotiating
we didn't do that we said
we don't care
we dissed them completely we we
completely dissed them repeatedly
and and so when you're a sovereign state
and you're facing what you believe to be
existential risk it doesn't even matter
if you're right
if they say to you we don't care about
your feelings
you know in a marriage that's a divorce
and in in a battle like uh we're facing
in ukraine now that becomes a war now on
top of that you had you know a hundred
thousand a's off battalion guys amassing
in mario paul and the azov battalions a
bunch of nazis and the press will say
they're not you go pre-2022 and you find
out yes they're nazis and you watch john
mearsheimer talks and he tells you all
about the nazis and here's hammer's
brilliant actually steve wahl brilliant
there are smart guys out there saying
this is 100 nato's fault this war did
not have to occur if nato had been able
to behave itself
how much of them
how much of like the nato uh activity i
call it almost like uh uh flexing for
social media
right there's like this like mainstream
conversation and you almost are trying
to score points on social media to some
degree although not you know they don't
count in likes and retweets and all that
but society has shifted and so there's
not the um i don't know i call it like
uh top hat diplomacy
right that we that we may have expected
50 60 70 years ago and and they weren't
perfect but there definitely was this
element of uh gentleman's diplomacy
diplomacy to some degree
and sure there was negotiations they
would listen there was a conversation uh
and yes sometimes we did go to war
obviously with the two world wars and
and things like that where there was
disagreements
but it feels like this to your point
is something else like it almost feels
like an unforced error that just came
from the lack of uh diplomacy and so
naturally
it feels like you get war and maybe we
didn't have to get this
well it feels to me like there's
cold warriors
sort of calling the shots
and we're
we're
in theory not in the cold war
and so you it feels like there's guys
who just can't come to terms with the
idea that we don't have to oppose russia
with every ounce of our being
i i just don't see what russia has done
to justify this
they say oh they took crimea i mean
these are these are border skirmishes by
u.s standards what happened to monroe
doctrine what about just saying stay out
of the state of the western hemisphere
dudes
um
and i just don't think it's our job
to be patrolling the baltic states
to be patrolling all these countries
that that are constantly changing
borders constantly
right if you look at a map you ever seen
one of those dynamic maps where it shows
the borders change over time they're
just flapping around constantly it's
europe it's europe is a gigantic
pile of tribalism
and it's always been that way right
germa germany wasn't even a country
until after the middle ages right
germany was just a bunch of
bearded crazies running around the dark
forest
trying to invade ancient rome
great ride exactly exactly exactly
they were the only ones who didn't get
conquered when you think about um
afghanistan and our withdrawal from
afghanistan which i think by most
people's standards was botched at best
uh how much of that fed into the
americans lack of appetite to
participate on the ground in ukraine
versus you think it's more of a
generational
just it didn't matter if we had botched
that or if we had withdrawn at that
moment uh the american citizen doesn't
have nearly the appetite for war that
maybe we once had decades ago
well the term botch i would question
because um
because it was so bad that
it had to be intentional
it really had to be intentional i i
swear
that you and i
could sit around with a six-pack
and come up with a better withdrawal
right
in fact we wouldn't need the six-pack i
mean the six-pack would help but um
and so if you look at every facet of the
withdrawal they left the weapons intact
they left the keys in the ignition they
left ballots of hundred dollar bills um
they left an army that they said would
defend the country there's no
and they lasted what about 30 seconds
there's no way the cia didn't know that
this army wasn't ready there's no chance
no chance
they were on u.s payroll
the second we pulled out they were going
to go off u.s payroll guess what you
don't have an army if you're not paying
them
and so so nothing about it makes sense
unless the idea is
that what it really represents is us
saying to the taliban hear the keys
we're leaving your weapons
behave yourselves here's what we expect
and there's money to put gas in the
vehicles
and uh
and uh have a nice day
now
the only thing i can't explain
is why we had to do it in a way that was
so humiliating
and that always takes me back to
how do you know where the motivation
comes from when the president of the
united states is so compromised
and i know those people won't agree with
that but he had dirty dealings in
ukraine he had dirty dealings in china
who knows how many more he had around
the world
if someone says do it do it ugly and and
they own you
you do it you do it ugly right
when we look at uh
the i don't know takeover of afghanistan
uh by the taliban uh for i don't know
the hundredth time as empires have gone
there and
been unsuccessful uh the two things that
stuck out in my head one was uh
a thought of history and another was one
that i read on the internet and the
thought of history was just in the first
time that we gave the taliban weapons
right it just this time was uh more so
they took them from us after we left
them versus us literally sending them uh
to help arm the rebellion you know
decades ago uh but the other thing i
read um and and i i want to say was from
tim kennedy uh who is a uh a former uh
special forces sniper or may still still
be uh active um but but maybe for
somebody else and he said listen
we have on national television
videos of the taliban sitting inside a
building there's a bunch of them sitting
there
i got a great idea let's just go drop a
bomb if we really if we really really
feel like these people are thriving
with them charlie get the [ __ ] out of
here
you know what why
during the withdrawal
are we basically
uh it appears to be getting more
information identifying where folks are
literally have a live video feed all
these different things
and we just walked away and maybe that's
all
that gets back to the fact that they
could have turned it ugly fast
so
so i mean the surrealist moments of all
were where we had
u.s citizens
outside
the the air air force base
fence that we're not letting in
and and and and they said look throw
these people on planes get them out of
there and and and jen pasake saying well
we couldn't identify who was who and i
go since when does that matter to you
guys
you're bringing in gazillions over every
border best i can tell
so so and then they said they got 90
percent of people wanted to get out and
i'm going that may be a good stat
for a snow plow or something but it's a
bad stat for getting us citizens out of
a hostile territory
and and and they were so matter of fact
about that and then there was then
there's this question if you know you're
going to pull out
why would you let why would you give
visas to a group of school kids to go on
a big adventure in afghanistan right
there's just nothing about the thing
that makes sense so so when nothing
makes sense and it means the model is
wrong and you have to have a new model
my new model is is that and by the way
you know you know those those u.s
citizens left behind have you seen any
stories about the horrors that they went
through afterward
any
no
none
right they're as silent as that as they
are on the vegas shootings right
my favorite um
and so
so it's not what it
it's not what we were told and i don't
know what it is right i don't know i i
the layer of the onion they're showing
this is not the right one the layer of
the onion i'm sitting at might not be
the right one either yeah there's times
when i'm talking to my brother i go we
talk about okay which which event
history would you like the answer key to
which is the one where you'd like to say
okay
tell me what the hell just happened
right
when some people say 9 11 some would say
some would say you know pearl harbor
tell me who knows why but but but but
there's there's these events i i don't
even know if we know what history is
anymore i i've i've
you know the the press has been owned by
the military
for decades long before they
officially became prostitutes
they were still uh in bed with the
military and it was considered the loyal
thing to do so you know during world war
ii you know the movie theaters were
putting out anti-japanese anti-german
cartoons and it's always been there
right they japanese had tokyo rose you
know whatever
um but now it's gotten to the point
where the press is entire business model
depends critically on whoring their way
around
um propaganda
explain that
well so the internet destroyed the press
at some level the conventional press got
wiped out right
and uh
and so how are they paying the bills
and and it's no longer
dan rather and walter cronkite going on
tv and telling us um what might not have
been true but we all were happy as hell
thinking it was true
and on sunday morning talk shows you'd
have five or six guys sitting around a
table
and you got the sense that they were
discussing
um
important topics from different angles
and you had george well with a super
right wing thing and you had lefties
they would go back and forth and with
civilized debate and you you got the
feeling that that that they were sort of
peeling back layers to the onion for us
and you get none of that now you don't
get it on fox news you don't get it on
on cnn
um
to the extent i lean right i like the
lies coming out of fox news better
um i think there's one journalist who
looks like one conventional journalist
who looks like he's trying to get a ride
nests tucker carlson i think people
think fox is this homogeneous right-wing
machine it is by no stretch of the
imaginations of that there's degrees but
there's the stupid talking heads who
just are
are propaganda machines themselves um
but but but there's i i depending on
what time of day you're watching fox
news you get a very different
presentation of history
so um so the press the press is the
press
is now subsidized
and i think that probably
uh
they're kept alive by
um
by the political system
right
and um
they're kept alive by um
75 of their ad revenues come from pharma
so if you want to know how the hell we
keep not getting a straight answer on
things like vaccines and coven all you
have to do is recognize that
that pharma my brother said something
the other day that struck me as profile
you know those tv commercials where they
advertise a drug and you go what the
hell did they just tell me right there's
a bunch of old guys walking around with
smiles on their face what drug was that
my dog is killing me here
and she doesn't take no for an answer he
doesn't think no for an answer um
and and you don't know what the drug was
and you don't know why you know oh yeah
i'm going to run off and take who the
[ __ ] cares uh right and and
you wouldn't do that and he said no i i
think what they're doing is that they're
just
advertising as a revenue stream
so if your farm instead of having a
lobbyist you know you say okay look just
throw throw some [ __ ] ads right
advertise our you know anal cream right
i don't care what
just advertise and so 75
of the advertisement revenues are from
pharma why because then when you have
some big catastrophe like vioxx or
orbextra or nexium or any there's so
many
um
what you do is you say oh by the way
don't cover that story
and they don't cover the story you think
that's by the way you think that's oh
yes oh yeah absolutely absolutely
you
was there on any tv show early on
a debate about the pros and cons of
vaccine
on any on any mainstream press
did a bunch of smart guys sit around the
table on sunday and say well you know
what are the pros and cons of vaccine
let's consider you know risks effect you
know people don't seem to know this
the history of vaccines is a horrifying
history not horrifying in terms of evil
dudes
although there might be some of that but
just horrifying in terms of how hard it
is to create a vaccine that doesn't
slaughter people it's a very difficult
thing and so there's books on vaccine
production that pre-date cobit
then talk about all the failures
that occur how they've got vaccines for
things in the military but they can't
use them because it kills kills the guys
and uh so making a vaccine's heart did
anyone discuss that did anyone discuss
in any way shape or form how would
did any of the press talk about
now you can hear it now but don't forget
this is just recently
it's as though they said okay we're done
now so go ahead talk about it all you
want we don't care
but did early on did anyone talk about
um vaccine injuries did anyone which are
absolutely real absolutely real we just
don't know the numbers because the
authorities who would have to keep track
of them the big grand overarching group
that would really be needed to keep
track of all of them
are a bunch of liars and so they're not
going to cover them
nothing was covered
nothing but propaganda and so this gets
back to the frontier justice part
there's some there was a story the other
day i read about a woman
about um
two one is a one is a husband and wife
team
talked about the kid the husband didn't
want to vaccinate the wife did
she took the kid to get back sick he got
wiped out by it
um
can imagine divorce court in their
future another is where they had a kid
who who had serious autoimmune issues
their doctor and the family all agreed
they're not going to vaccinate the kid
goes to school and they bribe them with
pizza and they vaccinate them and [ __ ]
them up royally
explain to me why that father doesn't go
and blow some his head off
it's not that i think he should
it's not that i think it would be good
it's not it's that i don't understand
statistically how these things are
happening and somehow
the only shooters we get are random
shooters who kill random people for no
apparent reason
i don't remember that remember the la
cop who declared war on the la police
department years ago
i i don't want to guess that his name
but i think it was eric something uh i
do remember they yeah and they basically
tracked them
they tracked them to like a cabbage or
something right i think they burned them
they burned them they set it on fire
yeah i read his manifesto he was not
insane he was not a loner he was not
isolated he cared about life he just
decided he'd seen enough
i i don't understand
let's go to
uvalde how do you have
so here's a town that's a town of 15
000.
it's 50 miles from a nearby bigger town
70 miles or 80 miles from a different
one it's in the middle of nowhere
and the number they say is they had 370
cops there
how do you get how do you get 370 cats
i i don't understand that
what were they doing there right so
right away the story starts getting
slicky
and then you've got
77 minutes where a bunch of cops
won't go in
and you so and the problem is
the explanations don't make sense to me
so i say oh they're cowards
really
i would think that you could pick
10 names out of a phone book
and one of those 10 would go in and say
[ __ ] you i'm not waiting i hear gun
chests i'm going
and the and out of out of all these cops
no one went in until supposedly some
border guard went in and shot him did
you watch it did you watch the hallway
video
yeah
i watched it
and
you know again uh hindsight
is 20 20. and so obviously we know what
happened but given that we know and
you're sitting there and you're watching
it
your blood just boils you you just are
the problem you're just getting so
i just don't think it could be true
what do you think i don't have i don't
know
i i i have been bothered by all the
shootings for years now
for years i've been bothered the
shootings all follow similar patterns
uh the man on the street who gets
interviewed minutes after it occurred
are always talking about multiple
shooters and they go away and
also just a single lone shooter by the
way have you ever seen a detailed
discussion
of of one of the shooters
lives
you ever seen anyone talk about what led
up to it what was the what was the setup
no you see a drug addled kid in court
looking wacky as [ __ ] getting convicted
sent away or getting executed or
whatever
and you get no insight you get no
backdrop you don't know anything
and and
um again my favorite if you want to dig
into it the vegas shooting was a
complete fraud
it's the most extraordinary story i
wrote about 20 pages on it and i only
got about 20 percent of the story
i don't know i don't know much about
that one what what happened well there's
two documentaries now which you can go
on if you go on rumble rumble or bit
shoot you can't get it on youtube
because of course they won't let it be
there um
and and what happened is stephen paddock
supposedly shot
uh
something like 1500 rounds out of a
34-story window in the mandalay bay
right
um
right away the chief of police who
apparently wasn't given the plot in
advance um
said there's no way it's not humanly
possible for one person to shoot this
many rounds
then within a day saying it's the only
one shooter
um but it turns out that there's there's
the documentaries one things that i pick
up right away is that they kept
interviewing the same guy over and over
and over the networks were using one guy
there were 20 000 people there but
somehow again mike crock
was the only guy who kept getting
interviewed
and youtube kept rolling to the next
interview like it does you know 15
seconds later and there's my cronkite
new network same guy his story's
drifting
it started out with him saying his buddy
got shot three times in the chest now a
marksman told me from that distance you
can't get shot three times in the chest
unless the guy's a sniper
and
and uh because there's too much spray
and um
and then the guy mike crock's talking
about his friends sticking his fingers
in his own bullet holes
to stop the bleeding
i'm going no right away that was my
[ __ ] meter that was my [ __ ]
moment
and then you started listening to audios
which by the way were getting deleted
off youtube as fast as you can find them
um
audio she can just hear all sorts of
weapons going off just tons of that
quack quack quack you know you hear all
these different guys took the recordings
they pulled all the different weapons
apart said here here's one that
superimposed on another here's one
and
um stephen paddock had no history of
guns or anything i think
i think he might have been a gun runner
that's my suspicion but i think he took
the first first bullet
and the question is um
and then there was there's always the
post thing that occurs remember in
january 6 when four cops committed
suicide
you go what
poor cops committed suicide after
january 6. well there was a bunch of
very strange deaths of people who
survived the original shooting too
like six or seven people out of twenty
thousand within a month we're dead
you go what's that all about i don't
know i just know so if you find the
videos if you find the documentary on
the las vegas shooting i bet you to
rumble and you watch it
you'll see the problem they were
shooting all up and down the strip there
was literally a lady walking through the
crowd saying to people in 45 minutes
you're all going to die
i mean just strange [ __ ] like this and
there's there's there's taxi cab footage
where the guy's going he's shooting out
of the fourth floor window shooting out
of this issue now that there's video
footage of the cops going into the room
and saying turn off your cameras right
that's the favorite trick
and then one guy didn't turn off his
camera and that survived and you're in
there and there
they say there's no broken windows then
you hear a window smash
it just surreal [ __ ] it just doesn't
make sense so and then the question is
okay the biggest shooting since the
civil war
the biggest shooting since the civil war
when was the last time someone mentioned
it in their rally and try to get rid of
guns
never
right you don't you don't know [ __ ]
about it because it's old enough who
cares well the reason they don't care is
because they botched it badly enough
that that it can't be used as a rallying
cry they don't want anyone looking the
guy the you know the guy got shot in the
leg the security guard who was actually
on the floor where panic was
he supposed he got shot in the leg
um
trauma surgeon said by the way these
weapons do a special kind of damage
you'd bleed out just from a leg shot
just because it turns your leg to jello
supposedly but but this guy gets said
that like next thing you know
reporters are trying to get to his house
and there's a bunch of
cars without license plates in front of
him the house is protected next thing
you know you find out he has several
social security numbers next you know
he's in he's in mexico
when asked about him going to mexico i
said well he planned to vacation i go
you know i think letting him go to
mexico was probably not a good move and
then he comes back he does one interview
on ellen degeneres which is own her
shows owned by mandalay bay
and uh
the whole story is nuts from head to toe
so here's the problem
once you see one plot like this if your
moment was pearl harbor couldn't have
been pearl harbor the way it went down
um
you know 9 11 whatever it is once you
once you wrap your brain on one of them
there are no there's nothing to
constrain you from pondering crazy ass
ideas and so you can't say oh that would
never happen
you you can no longer say that
and there's just too many of these
there's there's too many things that
just don't make sense you know there's i
don't know [ __ ] about it but you know
the israelis sunk one of our destroyers
and no one ever talks about that except
for the guys who care about it
um
you know it's been going on since the
dawn of time the lusitania was a setup
right i
i don't think we started a war without
some sort of
false flag
initiation of the war right right
so dave let me ask you this question
because i think a lot of people who who
listen to this right there's um
i'm probably melting their circuits
unfortunately well unfortunately in
society there's basically uh a move to
the extremes right and so there's some
people who i imagine are listening to
this and they're sitting there shaking
their head like yes he gets it he you
know he's he's talking about the things
that i believe i see
and then there's others that are like oh
my god this guy is an absolute insane
you know
extremist conspiracy theorist etc
how do you
balance
um maybe rationality when it comes to
things that you are confused by because
what i'm hearing you say and correct me
if i'm wrong is hey there's a bunch of
stuff that seems really weird but i
don't have the answer right it's not
like you're saying hey
the story you're being told is a but
really the story is b what i hear you
saying is i got details you know one two
three four five six and they don't add
up to me and now i'm confused and i
don't know what to think so how do you
kind of
maybe go through
the world as we have so much access to
information
where
there are a lot of things that don't
seem to add up like do you just
sit and think about them all day do you
just throw your hands up and say i'm not
gonna solve it and like let me move on
to the next one like how do you kind of
just navigate all this
well after a while they they get matter
of facts so i'll see something yeah i'll
see some stat about the vaccine killing
people like i i know i'm done
i i i've come to terms with so i write
about it right one things i do is i
write about it if
if if your
ideas are incoherent writing about it
tends to reveal that
and now it's not to say i i'm not clever
enough to write a plot i did a podcast
recently with a guy whose worldview and
mine don't match up
and and he knows a ton of facts
but but in some sense we all have like
this christmas tree we hang the
ornaments off it we what we do agree is
that the world's screwed up
he just has he he has this sort of davos
leaning and i say i i think china's
involved you know
and we disagree on that
and and the problem is you can reach a
point where you've got a model that's
robust enough that you can make anything
hang off it that doesn't mean it's right
as a chemist
by way of background i i went into a
very complicated field that some thought
we'd never understand and some thought
they did
and for 40 years i'd i've discovered
over and over and over that what experts
who are really trying to get it right
got dead wrong
they not they asked the wrong question
you wouldn't believe things were where
where i i could say to a freshman here's
why this isn't even possibly a valid
argument right and you go ah [ __ ] i
hadn't thought of that and so it's a
very complex field and just 40 years of
relentlessly showing that what people
thought was not true i'm finishing a
paper right now in which there's
probably 500 papers in literature i'll
use the same mechanistic model to
explain it and it was
just in a different zip code when you
actually dug into it
so i'm comfortable
with the idea that experts can be wrong
and over the years i've gotten
comfortable with the idea that that that
psychopathic people
conspire
last time we talked about this
yes
yes
how you know you know you know who's
nuts the guys who think that people who
who are in positions of power don't
conspire
those those people need a cat scan
either did they just there's just no
chance that's not true right
when you start to
extrapolate this maybe to uh financial
markets
is the same thing true
right
the non-financial markets are crazy
there's all these you know uh things
that don't make sense and then when we
look at the financial markets same thing
we saw major banks getting in trouble
for uh manipulating markets we've seen
you know issue after issue after issue
how much of it's true in finance as well
well the finance i i don't i don't get
as dark in the sense that um
you see greed and corruption
but it's it's in some level it's kind of
garden variety it's not a massive scale
the other thing is
there's
there's a non-trivial number of
instances where what
people attribute to nefarious dark
forces are just
20 somethings in cubicles running
markets around like crazy and just you
know bidding it up and bidding it down
and they're they're committing crimes of
course you know they're spoofing and
stuff like that but um
the bailouts of the banks
um
at some level you say well of course
they're going to bail out themselves
right
who wouldn't bail out yourself
and so uh i think the markets um
what has changed is that they've gotten
so financialized
um
i i
on twitter
you'd be hard-pressed to find
someone beyond
jesse felder and jon hussman talking
about valuations
i do it all the time
and and
the problem is is
valuation
doesn't tell you anything about timing
so i've been ranting about valuations
for a long time i think valuations
sort of escaped the gravitational pull
of of of the earth or tried to escape it
starting in 94. so i think we've been
drifting further and further from what
i'd call a credible valuation since
literally 94. why
well actually i i look at 25 metrics
evaluation i do every few years just to
touch base
and in 2021 i did it and and
you know if you're if your favorite
valuation is pe may god have mercy on
your soul they can fake those like
there's no tomorrow um but i use 25 they
have to do with price to book price to
revenue price to tobin's q
composite valuations price earnings you
name it um
there's a whole bunch of them and they
all kind of point to the same number but
as of the end of 2021 we're sort of a
hundred and
ten to 150 percent overvalued
historical fair value now what's
noticeable
is that if you look at all these
valuation charts and if people are
interested go to my pin tweet it's in
there
what's noticeable is they all seem to
peel away from historical
metrics
around 1994
and and
and what you can see is that uh
corporate debt took off in 1994 and
didn't look back
um corporate debt is a percentage of gdp
you know normalized the things that it
shouldn't take off um
that's part and part the credit cycle of
course um
but but
that now here we are with 20 of s p
being zombies right
and and if 20 of the s p can't pay their
their debt with their cash flow
the s p should be priced a lot lower
and um
and it's not right what happens when
those 20 percent default on their debt i
don't know is it possible is it possible
for us to get there or
is the constant intervention in markets
obfuscating that to the background and
so uh yes prices matter
but maybe we can't look at the
historical
measurements as like that's actually
where we could fall back to
well then you can't look at historical
returns either then that got presented
to me by my smart friend sitting at
dinner that night
he said maybe your historical metrics
are no longer valid and i said therefore
historical returns are no longer valid
if if you're paying twice
for a revenue stream then you used to
pay
long-term sustainable is is
you can't get a good return right
it's like if you buy a 30-year bond
right now
you know what you're going to get off
that bond
you can trade it if you want i'm not a
trader i'm not talking about trading
trading is uh
trading is part of the problem right
there's so much money sloshing around
that it has become the market
but it's not about investing
and and
um
and so if you buy a 30-year bond right
now what's the return on it three
percent three something five something
what i i lose track of these um i guess
the ten years close to three
um
unless you use the ten year if you buy a
ten-year bond it's going to return three
percent it's a predictable return you've
overpaid for that bond
right and if you think well i'm going to
sell to some sucker you gotta have a
ball but but that's not invested yeah
and someone has to own that bond all the
way to the end
what does your portfolio look like now
like what's the make up percentage-wise
um
i did some jiggling at the end of 2020
actually my portfolio is probably 35
maybe as much as 40
precious metals
um
there's i have some money in a in a
place that i count but i don't control
and it's a it's an old man's you know
30 70 fun sort of thing and and i have
no say in it and i i count it at the end
of the year but um so that's sort of
generic that's about one
seventh of my wealth
um that was an inherited chunk
um i i moved into energy at the end of
2020 which was
an absolute bottom call if that was the
bottom right you never know what it's
the bottom but if that was the bottom i
nailed it
i didn't size it like druckenmiller so
um i never do i always average in and
every once in a while i think it's
probably a good time to add some more
energy um
i think i think we're looking at an
energy
bull market
somewhere
in the energy sector for for decades
the problem is i don't i don't know how
to play it i don't know if it's energy
services companies i don't i think you
want to avoid
energy companies that have to develop
energy sources going forward in a big
way because i think i think the politics
makes that almost impossible now so i
think you want to i think you want to
buy energy companies in some sense
they're almost like royalty trusts where
they've already got their pipes they've
got the refineries they've got their
their wells and they can keep
pumping
the energy out of the ground
um
i i have a lot of cash that's uh that
was fine i didn't mind missing
opportunity but now the inflation is
causing trouble so that that i've been
desperate to figure out how to handle
that i own no bitcoin is you probably
surmise
um it's not that i don't think it could
do well it's just not me um i just
finished morgan housel's book on the
psychology of money and he gets at that
point very much he says what's what's
completely saying for you is insane for
me and vice versa that there's no right
and wrong on some of these things so
many things are how you're wired i'm i'm
not wired for bitcoin because it would
take me too long to understand it and i
would never forgive myself if i lost a
bunch of a serious amount of money
and i i would totally forgive myself for
not buying it because well for starters
i passed on it at 10 bucks
per coin
um
and i would have sold it at 50 and then
i would have been a psychotherapy for
the next 20 years um
and
and then um
yeah a lot of fixed income sort of stuff
and when you look out over the next 12
months 18 months we started the
conversation off with the feds going to
continue to hike rates potentially if
they did grow a spine until things break
are you doing anything different now uh
or kind of preparing for worse times or
just yes the portfolio you have is the
portfolio you have
but i am prepared for worse times what
what is different
and it's not different in you know
eternity different you know it's not
that this time it's different as in
unique although i would argue the
markets are uniquely frothy
um
i would say they've uh a new high
watermark for crazy um
what i'm preparing for
what i blew in 0-809
was that i was totally ready for it
but i
i i thought there had to be much more
damage and in defense of that view
is that i don't think anybody could have
foreseen
the level of intervention
and and and remember
when
uh the fed essentially bailed out
um
bailed out the system by putting 30
billion into jp morgan to take bear
stearns
that sucked the oxygen out of the room
30 billion people were stunned by that
and now we're throwing trillions around
literally trillions
and so i would say that the fed
has gone completely out of orbit in
terms of their willingness to intervene
and they they just didn't do that before
and i i did not see that coming and so i
saw
i saw
what came out of the 09 low is just a
dead cat bounce i thought i thought
we're going to be looking at a highly
damaging 90 correction
and if you buy a 90 if you buy a 90
correction after the first 50
you still lost let me do some quick math
80 of your
money
or as
einhorn said one night at dinner to a
tech bowl
it's a well-known phrase but this guy
was too
naive to know it
he said you know you know what a 90
correction is he says the 90 corrections
where you get an 80 correction then it
gets cut in half
he says he says
you have no experience
with something that gets cut by 90
or 97 einhorn lit into the guy
and uh what was the guy's response
he was just frothing at the high
profit margins of of uh of tech
not recognizing that that idea that
regression of the mean is a force of
nature and profit high profit margins
get scooped up
and and dealt with because if it's a
high profit margin competitors can jump
in and cause you trouble
and uh and so what you really want my
dad when i was a kid taught me he said
he went into a business that was capital
intensive during the 70s right where
capital was expensive
and and i said why did you go into that
business he was a contractor but this is
a weird offshoot for him
he said well beside the fact i think i
can make money is that
the fact that it's so capital intensive
sort of protects me against a wildcatter
because a shitty businessman can't get
the capital to do this he says i can
compete with a credible businessman we
can both play in the same field it says
it's the guy who undercuts me and
destroys us both simultaneously that i
can't deal with so he was describing a
moat right and and capital constraint
is a moat
for those who have access to capital
and the what the fed did
is the fed took our savings
which uh
used to be the capital right savings was
capital
and they said they took away that roll
of of savings as as capital and they
said look you don't need to you don't
need to borrow from dave
we'll lend it to you
and so they they made
they started by making my capital worth
less and then they've reached the point
where they're risking making it causing
my capital to be worthless
and as we
watch everything play out around the
world d globalization seems to be a
major theme uh reshoring of
manufacturing supply chains even
potentially labor seems to be something
that over the last two and a half years
has become a more obvious thing
what's the impact on financial markets
uh kind of like the macro trends for the
next 10 15 20 years do you feel like
deglobalization and reshoring of some of
these things
uh will change where returns can be
captured or is this still the same thing
just go buy great businesses uh and
don't worry about some of these kind of
macroeconomics maybe like a peter lynch
you know if you spend 15 minutes on
macroeconomics you spend 13 minutes too
many
uh
i think the globalization reassuring uh
will be massively inflationary
okay so so so i you know this murray
style horizon kinetic said the age of
monetary policy is over so that miracle
russian resources chinese labor credit
cycle of 40 years
that provided a tailwind for the equity
markets uh the boomer demographics peter
zeonta is a total demographic account
and when your demographics are favorable
which they were for the last 40 years
then you've got this this massive
workforce just showing up and cranking
[ __ ] out daily right and and you have a
relatively small percentage of the
population who were consumers and only
consumers
we're now heading into an aging global
population but certainly in the united
states but china supposedly is much
worse
um
where you got a growing number of
consumers who are expecting to have
things done for them and they don't they
don't have to pull on the ore anymore
they were retired
and uh
and so you're gonna have demand for
goods and services and and a smaller
number to provide them that's a highly
inflationary setup
so whatever your model is going forward
i think it better deal with that problem
and
um
the other thing inflation does is it it
shifts
money into the hands of the rich
because because because financialization
certainly doesn't help joe six-pack
and and we could have all sorts of
strife
all sorts of stress all sorts of
populism all sorts of
dumb presidents right
and so i
it's it's not to say that it it
charlie would you please shut up get in
the office go go defend yourself
um
where the [ __ ] is
there he is right there i got three dogs
only one's being a pain right now um
this too shall pass right
yeah but it's
but you know
you know the depression was only 10
years i i argued the depression's 15.
um
i got an argument with a stanford
economist who said no
no you're wrong about that i said that
you know low consumption during world
war ii blah blah blah and he said no
the gdp during world war ii went up 15
something like that
and and after about 10 years i i took
them on in writing i said no
your gdp number is wrong because gdp
should include depreciation of assets
so if you crank out
a drill
you can get 10 years out of that drill
if you go to the movies you get two
hours out of that movie so they just
they're not equivalent contributors to
gdp
um
and uh
in world war ii gdp might have been
rocking but we were making battleships
and bombs and planes and stuff like that
and the depreciation rate on those was
measured in in very short time scales
now what we did do during world war ii
is we
we
made great progress towards improving
mass production so we took what henry
ford did and we put it on steroids and
so that was the uh
was what world war ii left us with was a
highly functional economy in a world
filled with unfunctional economies and
so so we were wealthy at the end of
world war ii but but but but world war
ii was i think the blow off of the
depression but it passed
to say okay so this too shall pass
but people suffered
right
world war ii passed the people suffered
the civil war passed but people suffered
and so
you know if you went and stopped on an
ant hill in your backyard you could stop
on it all goddamn day and the next day
you'd go out there and there'd still be
an anthill where
but there'd be a lot of dead ants too
i don't want to be one of those right
and you think that's basically what uh
what is likely to happen here is that uh
this too shall pass but there'll be a
lot of suffering uh for various groups
in between now and then
that's right that's right i mean
depression
unemployment was 25
i mean there were parents giving away
their kids they were
it was an awful time for some people
and you just don't want to be that
person so you have to prepare not to be
that person somehow yeah one of the
things um before we wrap up that that i
found uh absolutely fascinating was back
in 2020 uh i think it was in towards the
middle or end of march i wrote a piece
and i said um
unemployment could basically
eclipse
the
great depression unemployment numbers
and this was the week before we got the
first 6.6 million of unemployment claims
in a single week right so right before
it skyrocketed right
and uh
what i had done is i went and i just
analyzed a bunch of different sources
that i found that were telling me
at county levels or even at certain
state levels
of layoffs and of what they perceived to
be
this incoming gigantic leap
and so it made me go look at the great
depression unemployment numbers and
everyone knows the 25 number because
that's the big headline number but
actually it took three years before it
got up over uh 20 i think it was
something you know it was around uh
historic low you know kind of mid three
percent then it jumped to like eight
then it was like 15 and then eventually
we got up over 20. and it stayed there
for quite a while it was like i think it
was three or four years where we were
above 20 unemployment
and so
the point that i was trying to make at
the time was just like look you don't
have to ever hit 25 to have
as bad unemployment or worse than the
great depression and if you look back at
the numbers the official numbers from uh
kind of this covid situation we have to
14 unemployment in the united states
right well even if you believe those
numbers too um
you would have tough time arguing that
2020
that we
created any wealth whatsoever
right
we didn't produce anything people
weren't building houses they weren't
building buildings uh things were shut
down research programs and
pharmaceuticals were shut down oh
there's wealth creation maybe um
and um
and uh
and yet somehow at the end of the year
what was the market up that year
in
uh last year
2020 i think it was up like 15 or
something yeah and then in 2021 it was
up like i think 28 30 something like
that
right
that
the market has to at some level track
gdp
it's it you can't
you you can't grow the market faster
than you grow wealth which is crudely
speaking gdp
and and so
um and the gdp numbers are sketchy
there's a great book by the way in case
someone's still listening to our podcast
um
by robert gordon and wealth creation
and he said that 1870 to 1940 was a
phenomenal period of wealth creation
there's these primary inventions like
electricity and things like that
and then there's what he calls secondary
inventions which is you know appliances
and so they spin off and he said
oddly enough the best decade ever for
secondary inventions was the 1930s
we created a lot of wealth in the 1930s
um
and uh
and um and he said then then it goes
pretty flat
i got two dogs working you know then it
goes pretty flat from 1940 to sort of
1970.
and then uh and then he said it's it's
it just pancakes that real wealth
creation just pancakes like crazy going
forward he said there was a blip from
the decade from 95 to 2005 which was the
tech thing
he said but then it just flattens out
again and and uh
and and he
draws some real interesting analogies
what is really transformational wealth
and you can say ah look at amazon well i
would say more transformational than
amazon was the sears robot catalog
the sears robot catalog was was the
prototype of amazon you got this catalog
you could order anything of any one of
ten thousand things before that you had
to go to your your your country store
and buy nails out of a barrel show like
that and you can buy prefab houses and
[ __ ] through the serious robot catalog
parts for your car it was amazon
so amazon is not as transformational as
fears
and
and and we we brought electricity you
know the wright brothers one of the
wright brothers lived to see god damn
these dogs
live to see jets
oh my god
how is that possible how do you how do
you go from inventing air flight
to seeing jets in in your lifetime
and so i i think that the modern economy
is hugely
a hollowed-out thing right so
you got tesla which is inventing ideas
but
but the actual wealth creation is is is
still
hard to detect
um
this market cap is way out of proportion
to what it actually produces uh you've
got facebook that if it went away today
the world would be a better place
you got what it was netflix netflix is
a poor man's hbo
charlie get the [ __ ] out of here
um
he is a
boston terriers that are half bulldog
half carrier the bulldog part shows up
occasionally
dave real quick the book that you're
talking about is called the rise and
fall of american growth by robert gordon
and that's brilliant it's brilliant and
in the description on amazon uh it says
in the century of the civil war an
economic revolution improved the
american standard of living in ways
previously united imaginable electric
lighting indoor plumbing home appliances
motor vehicles air travel air
conditioning and television transformed
households and workplaces with medical
advances life expectancy between 1870
and 1970 grew from 45 to 72 years and
then it says gordon challenges the view
that economic growth can or will
continue unabated and he demonstrates
that the life altering scale of
innovations between 1870 and 1970 can't
be repeated he contends that the
nation's productivity growth which has
already slowed to a crawl will be
further held back by the vexing
headwinds of rising inequality
stagnating education an aging population
and the rising debt of college students
in the federal government
this episode is brought to you by ledger
the best crypto hardware wallet
everyone's heard the phrase not your
keys not your coins and that's more true
today than it's ever been
ultimately a value proposition of
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies is
self-custody where you get to retain
ownership over your digital assets that
is what ledger specializes in they've
got multiple pieces of hardware and they
also have the ledger live mobile app
which makes it seamless to not only
retain control over your bitcoin but it
also allows you to interface with
exchanges lending platforms and other
types of software products if you're
interested in upping your self-custody
game go check out ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self-custody you'll thank me
later
so so and
and the people who have iphones and
stuff are going well that's just not
true but you go okay um
tell me how many times you have to do
something online where it doesn't
frustrate the [ __ ] out of you things
that just shouldn't have been put online
now is online
and
and you know
i'm always amazed how many websites
would benefit from just looking at how
amazon puts their website together so i
give them full credit for optimizing
what it is they do i think they've done
a phenomenal job but there are so many
com again netflix baffles me
and then we replace exxon from the dao
with salesforce.com what the hell is
salesforce.com you'll say oh it's
cloudness or cloudbeen i go then how
about google if you want to do it why
would you put in salesforce.com
and and i think they are
that they're they're they're translucent
companies
they're just it's just not that good in
my opinion and and uh
and and and
they're not transformational i i mean
progress is always forward even during
the inflationary 70s progress moved
forward
you know and transistors were invented
and stuff like that i can't remember the
60s i guess was the transistor
but um
the other thing buffett recently i'm not
a big buffett fan i respect his ability
to to grow
wealth not grow wealth grow
personal wealth um
not create wealth but
he pointed out that um
that five of the six biggest companies
in the world are us-based companies
and if you look at them they are these
translucent type companies
um
not that they haven't got we are you
barking now you [ __ ]
jesus christ and um
and uh but he pointed out he said if you
look back 20 years here's the 20 biggest
companies in the world
or 30 years
um
and 14 of the 20 were japanese
and he said 30 years from now
it'll look that different again
so here's a guy who's always saying
oh never bet against america who's
saying 30 years from now the five out of
the six biggest companies will not be
american
and and and so in some sense he's
he's trashing himself he's trashing his
own model
and uh
so the next 30 the other thing
i keep going back to the xehan book
zehan got into my skull last week um
um
it's it he he's worth paying attention
to i i don't i i
i shouldn't talk about him because i'm
still working my way through it but
zehan's thinking is that he's
overconfident but he's he's uh he's
worth listening to
um
never mind um
the future will not look like the past
that's the safe statement
um i think
this
next recession
will be a killer because we have too
much debt
the federal reserve has no ammo to fake
our way out of it
um oh and i kept trying to get to a
thought that um those three things that
occurred
four or five things that occurred
momentously over the last 40 years that
won't repeat
one of the things they did is they
created an equity market
there was this relentless series
of v bounces
so the market would try to correct
and then it would bounce right back
and someone who says that a 20 drop that
rallies back to where it was before
within a year
if you want to call it a correction have
a ball it corrected nothing
precisely nothing all it did was
reinforce the idea that you can't lose
investing in stocks now oh a guy you
want to pay attention to very very off
radar off screen uh is going to add
macquarie at uc irvine and he's analyzed
markets back a couple hundred years
and and he talks about you know equities
and bonds
they break even ben graham said that too
they break even
the only
if you take the bond market disaster
post world war ii
you know mid a couple of decades there
the 200 years
equities and bonds tie each other and
set and and graham said anyone who who
thinks equities necessarily be bonds in
return
is delusional
now maybe maybe things have changed now
but regression of the mean will occur it
always does
and if you look at something that's way
way way off any sort of historical
metric
i don't know when but you got to assume
it's going to regress
the bet as to when is dangerous but the
bet to bet that it won't progress
that's the most dangerous
yeah it uh the it's the mean for a
reason
right yes yeah in fact it's in fact what
the fed has done is prevented it from
from ever going below the mean you know
the markets weren't even that cheap in
oh 809
they
they were below fair value for about a
month
and i said that when i was at a dinner
with um
mark spitznagel who's one of these deep
zen types um
and he concurred and jeremy grantham too
they both said look they were below fair
value for the the shortest period of
time
so so if if the horrific collapse of
everything
caused the markets to spend
a month below fair historical fair value
what did you correct
and people you know when the markets
were down twenty percent people would
ask me colleagues ah the markets are
about twenty percent i'm getting real
nervous i said okay
a year and a half ago
i told you that you would not make any
money over the next year and a half
would you have [ __ ] your pants
the answer is no
they'll say yeah that would be fine well
i said that's what you just did
but the message also is we haven't
corrected anything we unwound a year and
a half of fraud
we haven't even gotten back to the i'm
not even sure we're back to the
pre-coven peak which was already at
disastrously high peak
and so i think we're going to unwind
i think the s p is going to unwind sub
2000
i i i had something jar me a little bit
yesterday
that made me wonder if my mass a little
off but i i i actually think we could
get that at twelve hundred
twelve hundred
yeah
i think it's that far out of whack 1200
would be below historic
fair value comfortably below
there's people right now who are going
to hear you say that and they're going
to go shut their computer and what go
for a walk outside well go go look at my
pin tweet look at the 25 metrics
evaluation and ask if you unwind those i
i think the 25 point to about a 65
correction
where does that get you to get to the
mid teens
and and that only gets you to the mean
and you and i both know that you're
supposed to spend half your
statistically weighted time below the
mean
for it to be the mean so you can say ah
the means now change okay
um
ed not um
um ron griese
and he goes by the name the chart master
sent me a plot one day that i'd never
seen i've never seen anyone else post it
and i don't know why
it is the return
of the uh of the s p over the 20th
century last hundred years
corrected for the m2 money supply
and it's dead flat
it's not gently sloping it's dead
flat
is it possible
that that's the way to correct for
inflation that's a milton friedman
correction right that's money supply
is it possible
that the actual capital gains in the
market to the last 100 years
are zero corrected for m2
probably
what that means is all you get are
dividends
and the evidence
that we're way over fair value is that
the dividends are half what they used to
be they used to be around four or four
and a half
now they're terrible
but i do see opportunity a bad secular
bear market will hurt everybody
but if you're super patient i think the
energy sector looks good
i would rather buy it in a horrific
sell-off
um
but the inflation's got me a little
edgier than normal um
the lost asset class i keep throwing
this out and it
makes no difference the lost asset class
is platinum and platinum miners
go look up the three biggest platinum
miners sabine
and uh
and uh anglo-american platinum
and they have
dividend yields in the high single
digits cap net cash on the balance sheet
pe is the five
when i asked a friend at rbc for more
information on them because i'm sitting
there going what am i what am i missing
and by the way this is with platinum not
having moved in 20 years
so they're printing money
without platinum helping them
and and and i asked a friend from rbc
for some of their inside information and
the data he sent me was five years old
and i said that's all you got he said
that's it
so they're not even being looked at
and so i own some of the platinum miners
they've gotten cheaper since i bought
them
and maybe there's geopolitical risk in
south africa
there's geopolitical risk in every
country best i can tell
um
and
i
so there's that
[Music]
i used to be a big fan of the tobacco
stocks not morally but financially but
then they went and bought vape companies
i kind of screwed that pooch
um
there are things out there that you
could buy if a gun got put to my head i
i still think i think the bear market
has started i think the secular bear
market has started
how long can it go
how long the nikkei
go
i would argue the nikkei is still in a
bear market i knew you would argue that
well if you own the nikkei in 1989
you're still underwater yeah
to me
to me the definition of a recession
being
the downturn
this [ __ ]
a recession if you think about what what
the recession the physical
interpretation of a recession is a dip a
hole a pivot a divot from your your sand
wedge
um
you're not out of a recession so you're
out of the hole if you're in a sand trap
on the upslope
are you out of the trap
no
so to me a recession should include both
the downturn and the upturn required to
get back to even
that's a recession to me
the nikkei
if you if you bought the if you owned
the nikkei in 1989 you're a 55 year old
businessman it's now it's now uh 30 some
odd years later you're an 88 year old
businessman
and you're under water
right you're not a businessman by the
way you're just a broke old guy and and
you couldn't trade it
i think the markets could become
uninvestible
let's say the nikkei was the known
universe
they'll say that's all you had but it's
a big market it was the most famous
country of its time for investing
um
you couldn't do anything with the nikkei
for for decades
there was no way to invest it
and and and i got i got into a george
noble who's way smarter than me but
and he said well you get short i said no
you couldn't
took too long
the erosional cost would kill you
you say oh you can do this and then he
has all these fancy things he said now
you're talking professional class
investing or trading
said
we can't do that i can't do that
very few people can do that
and um
so i think the markets could become
uninvestible the markets were
uninvestable in uh from 67 to 81.
they treaded water inflation unadjusted
they lost 75 inflation adjusted
over 14 years
how old are you now bob 34.
so so so when you're 50 years old and
you've gone nowhere inflation had you've
gone down 75 inflation adjusted it's
crazy
it's crazy
and the average investor doesn't know
that's possible
they've been told that can't happen
jeremy siegel by the way ed mcquarrie
tears jeremy siegel a new one from head
to toe
so ed mccoy wrote a couple of papers on
this and they're really he sends them to
me i don't know how he picked me out um
maybe i sent him an email
but in investing's just not supposed to
be this profitable it's it's buffett
said four percent a year
he said when you take out all the fees
everything four percent a year
jeremy grantham just quoted that same
number in a podcast i listened to
recently four percent if we buy amc
stock though we're gonna we're gonna
just go to the moon
the moon and back yeah
[Laughter]
it's that crazy it'll be like uh i do an
analogy between what's that one with uh
sandra bullock where gravity
yep i said this is not like gravity
you're not gonna get up and stagger away
on some beach somewhere at the end of
the movie
right
so we i i i've become rather dark right
i must admit um but i'm positioned such
that unless
the inflation really finds a way to
shred me
and by the way the fact that the metals
are not responding at all is rather
stunning gold miners look cheap to me
the gold miners are printing money now i
think um the one thing i'll say is uh
most of the assets that people would
have thought would be inflation hedge
assets
uh right that is true
except for if you're in a liquidity
crisis
and what i think we are watching is
exactly what we saw in 20 2008. and i've
talked about this over and over again
and you know frankly uh people who
understand what happened then and
understand how liquidity crisis worked
they kind of nod their head and say yep
okay that makes sense people who don't
just latch on to the fact that uh an
asset can only be an inflation hedge or
not right it's just this black and white
thing and if you go back to 2008 gold
went down 30 percent and that didn't
mean that it wasn't a safe haven it
didn't mean that it wasn't a
non-correlated asset over a long period
of time any of that stuff it just meant
that for those six months of the summer
of 08 when it went down 30 percent along
with everything else there was a
liquidity crisis and correlations went
to one or closer to sell whatever you
can yes and and uh
and uh
you know when i was a kid i i might have
told you this in a previous podcast i
was having a conversation with my dad he
was a great street level economist
running a construction business that
survived um
at one point i said to him i said so you
could get wealthy
buying real estate
in the 30s
this in high school i said this to him
and he said yeah but no one had any
money
and this somehow that planted the seed
of an idea in my skull that said you
have to have money at the bottom
which means therefore you have to have
money at the top
you can't hold on to [ __ ] to the bottom
and then get money
and so you you you really have to resist
the
irresistible urge to be invested when
being invested has been so profitable
now ironically he made a probably a
hundred fold off general electric
and i tried to talk him into selling it
because because i had paid attention to
jack welch and his and his and his bean
counting and stuff and i i knew that gm
capital uh
de capital was a problem and stuff like
that
but how do you convince a guy who's made
a hundred fold on a stock that he should
sell it
and why the hell should he listen to you
and and
um morgan households
one of his most
strong arguments in this book that again
i just finished
is that you really really really want to
resist the urge
resists the urge to to stop the
compounding
so one of the reasons why you have to
invest
by your own personal metric
is so that you don't bail
and so
i i try to buy an asset now in which i
use
michael barry's thesis that if if worse
comes to work you hang on to it
and that's not netflix and that's not
arc
that's none of those
that is kind of gold because you say
[ __ ] it right
um it's been around five thousand years
i'll hang out with it it is
it is i don't know quite a bit of rio
tinto
it would take an asteroid to take out
their mining operations
they have a big dividend they have a low
pe
and and they have cash on the balance
sheet and
i just feel good about that
i i don't i'm i'm avoiding every company
with debt
i can handle a little as long as the
debt's small relative to the revenues
and i say okay
yeah one exception is tobacco
dave
i literally could talk to you i think
for like two days straight no sleep and
we could talk about all the dark crazy
[ __ ] going on in the world so what do
you disagree with you i've babbled my
[ __ ] but where would you say oh [ __ ]
you know that that part's the part i
just can't sign off on
what what what part did you have to bite
your lip going oh [ __ ] we just lost our
we not only lost our audience which you
already ever acknowledged but but you
lost me too was there any part that i i
think they uh there's two pieces um
one i don't actually i don't know the
answer to either one of them but the one
thing i would challenge is this idea
that we're going to go into like a super
deep uh kind of painful recession
and i agree with the analysis actually
right that like that is where we would
be headed um
i probably have more confidence that the
fed
uh is going to wave the white flag pivot
and just start dropping monetary
stimulus all over the place again
you know well before we get to
i don't know can they do that though
here's the problem this is why the
inflation starts so important can they
do it with inflation screaming at them i
don't think that they have uh the
classic trade-off between inflation or
recession
right uh was all fed policy driven they
can do whatever now we have this
stagflationary period
and i think they're gonna have to choose
you're gonna have to bite the bullet on
one which one are you gonna bite the
bullet on and
my guess is
that
if you say we are going to prevent our
true on full you know catastrophic
recession and people will have to live
with high inflation
that is the lesser of the two evils
because
you and i will yell and scream from the
hill
what are you guys doing this is insane
inflation sucks all this stuff
but the average person yeah things got
expensive they have no clue what's going
on whereas i'm not sure that's true i i
think
they're going to blame somebody oh they
for 100
but the people who are responsible
aren't elected officials
and so from that standpoint uh you know
and if you really look at it like
powell getting reaffirmed uh reappointed
whatever you want to call it uh by biden
i think was actually a pretty important
data point on
okay we're now going to go across party
lines here we are going to uh kind of
hang our hat
on this approach less the person and
more of the approach uh and i'm always
careful to say like i don't think that
jerome powell if he was to be replaced
by somebody else wouldn't necessarily
look good or bad i just think that
somebody would do exactly what he's
doing like he's doing what their data
tells them to do and what their models
and kind of their framework is
we just live in a really really complex
time
where
you know as you know we've talked about
before
i don't think a human-led monetary
policy is ultimately up for the task of
navigating right a world of unknowns
right like i just i just find that uh a
losing battle
and so uh
i choose to uh
shield myself from it
you know in a major way right and that's
where obviously the bitcoin stuff comes
in
now the downside to it on a day-to-day
basis in the short term
if you're
not looking at it from an investment
standpoint you're not looking at it from
shielding you know your investment
portfolio all this and you're saying hey
uh i i live paycheck to paycheck right
going back to not having the 400
can you put your
economic wealth into an asset that goes
up a lot and down a lot and sometimes
the you know both of those in the same
week
well you know a little bit harder to
wrap your head around that and so i
think um
different people have different
objectives right and so i just find it
hard that the federal reserve will allow
us to go into some you know 08 style
uh recession
but
if they do
i then question um
so much does inflation come down as much
as just the base effect takes place
rather than this like base effect
eventually uh well i i'm not sure the
base effect
in countries where inflation gets out of
control they don't get saved by the base
effect yeah but but what i'm saying is
like if you look at uh so the zero
percent inflation from june to july
right they're celebrating saying you
know no that's not true though that's
just a lie of course there was there was
eight and a half percent inflation of
course and so that eight and a half
percent though remember i think it was
june of 2021 was the first month we had
over five percent inflation and it never
came back down we have now gone more
than 12 months with over five percent
inflation in the united states of
america and so if we have eight and a
half percent in july of 2022
that is now compounding
we are we're now in the compound
right
and so
um
and so
one thing we know
is that if inflation stays up
we are not going to be talking
five years from now about i don't see
how this has stayed up without causing a
problem
correct because because
if if you're losing 10 of your spending
power a year
and that goes on more than one year
again half the country is going to be
starving
pretty soon
so this this is a um
this is a countdown clock right here
this is a countdown clock and loss this
is um
so so this is not sustainable there's
the other that's the little one
she's a perpetual puppy um
the other thing that i would say to you
is uh again i agree with your analysis
on uh the non-financial events
a lot of the data points don't add up a
lot of the data points just leave you
scratching your head saying
what what is going on right right
and uh
i think it was actually you
who maybe two years ago i think you're
doing a podcast with marty bendt
and in it
you were going over your year in review
and you said something that always stuck
with i'm pretty sure it was you
who said you know the problem with the
climate change debate
is that most of the analysis that is
done
the thesis gets negated when the
experiments are done
and so naturally some portion of the
scientific community basically just
throws their hands up and says well we
tested all our other ideas so it must be
humans
right rather than go and prove here is
exactly what humans are doing but
whatever right
and
i kind of feel a little bit like uh when
you get into the really dark stuff not
not you uh personally but like just the
deeper you you go down these rabbit
holes uh and we all do it it's kind of
like um
uh it's kind of like the modern version
of uh the thing that you do that you
don't want anyone to know you do
except for there's some weirdos like you
and i that that we end up talking about
it right but like people get on the
internet and they start googling around
and they end up in some weird place and
then they're kind of like oh [ __ ] like
how did i get here you know whatever
but things don't make sense and so we've
now seen enough examples
where we're losing trust in institutions
or we feel like we're being misled or
whatever
we just immediately assume it's
nefarious
and i do wonder um
if if you try to fight that which is
very hard i mean i i fall victim to it
all the time
how much of it is just like
the world is weird we don't understand a
lot of [ __ ] and so like you can take a
bunch of data points and like the
natural conclusion may not be the actual
answer
versus
like no this shit's real dark and like
there's really [ __ ] nefarious things
that happen and like you know we just
happen to have uncovered the the data
points or the ingredients and so we just
haven't yet found the smoking gun that
you know ends up with the conclusion
and each situation is different right i
think it's i think it's easier to detect
the [ __ ] than to undo it and to
unravel it
and so i i you know
when you start catching people lying to
you so the climate change that's one of
the first tip-offs is that you start
running into big lies
and and and and
they actually philosophically believe
that their cause is so just
that that lying is legit it's sort of
like if trump's hitler then of course
you do anything to make sure that he
doesn't get reelected
and if you really think he's hitler
of course the dog's doing it again
if you really think he's hitler
then who who wouldn't do anything to
prevent him from getting reelected
and the mob psychology where you all
agree right you and your echo chamber
agree
that he's hitler
and so you you get reinforced
and i think to go down unconventional
paths you need some reinforcement
but there's an optimum in that curve
so you need reinforcement so that so you
don't feel so insane that you just can't
do it
so when i was buying gold in 1999
there was not much reinforcement but
there was a couple of key players who
were going you know this is looking like
a pretty good time to be buying gold
and and uh and without that i couldn't
have done it
and and when i was buying tobacco stocks
and i got i think it was like 2003 or i
can remember so long ago
when they were facing a big lawsuit and
stuff and and
it took me a while to piece together the
story to say
um
this lawsuit can't hurt him as soon as i
realized the lawsuit couldn't hurt him
i go oh these are a buy now
and um
and so
i can i think
i i think i'm okay at
generating enough concern digging out
enough data
to say okay the story we're being told
is wrong
but without being out enough data to be
able to say and this is the true story
because that's a totally different bar
that's a totally different standard
and and if they're really good at being
nefarious you could be 20 layers of the
onion were wrong
and you know all you have to do is like
things like you know
you don't remember but you know when we
found out that reagan was trading arms
for hostages and stuff and then you go
what really
and all of a sudden you find it wait a
minute we're we're we're we're now
allied with al qaeda or the taliban way
we're taking the bad guys at one point
so the very surreal world
and and and then you you you watch
someone like
like khashoggi get killed in the saudi
embassy
right
he's one [ __ ] guy
who cares
i mean who the hell cares he's one guy
in the saudi embassy you go to saudi
arabia you get killed excuse me that's a
darwin award as far as i'm concerned
and it's a shame for the family
but meanwhile the press completely
ignores tens of thousands being killed
in yemen by the saudis
one dead khashoggi versus tens of
thousands of yemenis
there's no way to explain
those two
in the contextually
the juxtaposition of those two facts
just doesn't make sense without invoking
geopolitical
nefarious
propaganda rich everything i i went back
and read edwin bernay's classic 1926
book on propaganda just to look at what
the godfather of the field
said about propaganda
we're slathered with propaganda it's
it's part of our culture so everything
when they try to sell you a car it's
propaganda
but where it gets dubious is is when the
government is using propaganda to get
you to sign off on just total dog [ __ ]
and
and now that the government is
50 of our gdp
it's you know back at the turn of the
century the other century
the government was like three percent of
gdp it didn't matter
right the world just it kind of ran
itself and the government was just yeah
you could get some senator to pass some
law that made your business work better
but
but now that
trillions and trillions of dollars are
being handed out so halliburton went
from being a company
that used to be involved in getting
energy out of the ground to a company
whose sole purpose is to get government
contracts
that's their entire business models to
get government contracts
and and and government's now so big
and the corruption therefore is so deep
and i think back to climate change
people say well you know big oil is
paying you i got
there's i have tried to find the thread
of big oil
to climate deniers i can't find it
and there's a lot of people trying to
say it's there i can't find it
what i can tell you is this the
the climate industrial complex on the
other hand they're projecting 150
trillion dollars to be spent on it
that's that that's serious money that
starts adding up after a while
and so again
for me the climate change story changed
when i
found out that they were lying their ass
off constantly
and and and we can talk about that if
you want i mean the first lie is that
there's no credible scientists who don't
believe it right that's the standard
statement the only guys who don't
believe it are not credible
nobel prize winning physicists all over
the globe have denounced it but no one
cares
the former head of the national academy
of science said it's the biggest hoax in
history
is he not credible the guy used to run
nasa's temperature monitoring program
says there's no there's no warming
the 500 phd scientists at nasa wrote a
letter saying please cut back on your
rhetoric
there's gazillions of people screaming
at the top of their lungs
that this story is wrong you know
doomberg right
i do bloomberg
is a smart bastard and i know his
background and he was highly placed
and he said when he gets into this
debate
he just points out that um
that that the equations are all
non-linear and anyone who does modeling
knows a non-linear a pile of non-linear
equations can't be solved
and so
so i no i i think
i think most of what we're being told is
a big lie
but does it matter most the time no
i've i've turned on pharma like you
wouldn't believe call the destroyed
pharmaceutical
i i think if
if you're taking if you're taking a drug
to lower your blood pressure
you should talk to your doctor
you got duped if you're taking nexium
you got dukes
if you there's there's just so many
there's so many drugs out there that
that
not only served no purpose
but that that my wife just took a drug
for uh she has a vomiting disorder
and uh
and dylan was working and stopped
working so we so i we went to doctors
recently and they put her on a new one
called lamotrigine or something
one in ten people
get a rash that sends them to the er
one in ten
is that
and can be fatal
the fda cleared that that's a miracle
drug to take that kind of risk
and i think the fda is now clearing
drugs
with no justification whatsoever i think
the fda has been completely commandeered
by big pharma
completely 100 percent
and and and i could be convinced that
there are good drugs
coming out still
i was involved in chantix in a very
peripheral way and
but but
i think so many of the drugs were taking
you know the drug from biogen that got
cleared for alzheimer's no
last year in the middle of the vaccine
push
biogen got a drug cleaned for
alzheimer's 56 000
a year
it turns out that the fda panel
i think 13 said no
and the 14 said i'm not sure
and the fda cleared it
i just found out
from a book i just finished on the fda
that they actually had
terminated the clinical trials
and then also now the blue they cleared
the drug anyways
so i think the pharmaceutical industry
has gone from trying to develop
legitimate drugs
to developing a business model where
they can push drugs through regardless
of their efficacy
and and and and they can win in court
of course it's it's a tax
and so i don't think i'll ever take a
drug which i can't identify
the positive effect so if i have an
infection i get it if i have a rash and
the steroid makes it goes away i get it
but if you say some level of something
of mine is too high or too low i'm not
taking it
the statins are a nightmare the whole
statin story the people taking blood
pressure modifying medicines there are
people who need it because they're super
high risk but they're they're they're um
they're giving it to everybody
they're saying oh your blood pressure is
160 over you know 100. you should we
should put you on a step
they did a clinical trial looking for
evidence that that was needed the
clinical trial failed didn't stop him
my my wife was on a drug called neuron
that said it was passed for
shingles pain
pfizer said okay let's see if we can get
this cleared for neuropathic pain
and it turns out that uh
it turns out that that they did a
clinical trial and they got nothing
nothing zero buckets
and and and then they called in a bunch
of experts and said look at the date
again make lemonade out of lemons find a
way and and the internal documents from
a court case said
nothing
this this group said it's over game over
not gonna happen they approached the fda
informally and the fda said don't bother
and what did they do they got a couple
of academics to write a bunch of
fraudulent papers
on the potential of neuron for
neuropathic pain in general
pfizer then bought a million
copies and they handed them out to
doctors all over the world
98 of neurons
market is off-label generalized
neuropathic pain
it's crazy
it's crazy so i believe here's what i
think has happened to farmer
they have picked all the low-lying fruit
period
they've got the antibiotics they've got
some antivirals and now they're they're
they're trying to go for lifestyle
they're trying to go for things that
just change who you are sort of
and um
and i think
therefore what it means is it's an
industry that should be shrinking
because
there are no longer low-lying fruit
and and
and instead of
naturally shrinking like people who made
wagons for a living in 1900
they have chosen to use um
graft corru and corruption
to keep their business model going
dave
i want to stop right there we're just
going
as a ending uh sentence
i think there's more of it in the world
than you and i uh want
uh uh to see or uh or admit to others
um there's a lot of people who may not
have heard uh our previous conversations
where can we send them to find you on
the internet uh or find the year in
review
or any of the other things that you
write
well if you search my name
david's column
and you're in review and then you put in
a date it's gotten harder because peak
prosperity changed their website but
you'll find year in reviews for each
year back about a dozen years um if you
go to twitter it's david b column is the
handle
i figure i'm not long for this world on
twitter i think they're i think i'm
close to getting voted
i just found out yesterday i'm betting
there's a bot that checks and seeing if
you're being silenced
and i scored worse than
alex berenson and james woods
so and there's very few people who are
scoring poorly and i i
they're i've noticed funny things so i
think i'm going to be on twitter
for a limited period uh but at david b
colum
the year in review from last year is my
pinned tweet
and and it's be careful it's not for the
faint of heart it's 300 pages
[Music]
we will definitely do this again maybe
we'll do it again when uh when you write
this year's uh yeah i wore you down i
think hopefully no hopefully you're
gonna write this year it's gonna be 400
pages
no it's not actually i i i i have to
invent i have to reinvent it somehow i
i've been thinking of various angles to
come just write a ten pager just like
super short 10 pages
the problem is you can't get into
anything then it just becomes a shallow
list of bullets
you can't digest the topic
that efficiently
that is very true
i'm just gonna have to leave [ __ ] on the
cutting room floor
all right my friend i appreciate it as
always uh every time i talk to you you
make me think much more deeply about
various uh aspects of the world but also
financial markets and uh we will
definitely do this again so i appreciate
your time today
adios muchacho was fun